we're beginning with the terrifying and
sad story today national schools are
opening under extra tight security while
police hunt for the gunman who killed
four people at a Waffle House restaurant
early Sunday morning police identified
the suspect as this man 29 year old
Travis Reinking
he's from Illinois the gunman was
wearing nothing but a jacket he was nude
when he opened fire early Sunday morning
with a semi-automatic rifle all four
people who died were in their 20s this
morning we're learning more about them
and a survivor who's being called a hero
for taking the shooters gun away
mark Strassmann is outside the Waffle
House in the Antioch section of
Nashville marca morning good morning
within a mile of this Waffle House
police say the gunman was naked on foot
heading to his apartment where he put on
a pair of pants and disappeared what's
especially worrisome to them they
believe he still has a hunting rifle and
a handgun I just heard gunshots you know
he was right behind this
Abita DaSilva was eating breakfast with
friends and family early Sunday morning
when a gunman naked from the waist down
walked in and opened fire and everybody
ran I went in the bathroom and all I
could think was where's my brother
his younger brother a key light was one
of the four people killed he looked up
to me but I looked up to him at the same
time because he was real smart he was a
real good guy never gotten in trouble
too many days just before 3:30 in the
morning Travis Reinking drove onto the
Waffle House parking lot he killed two
people outside then began shooting
inside he just wanted to spend his
ammunition once he got inside and there
was a bunch of rapid fires until it went
quiet when Reinking stopped to reload
his weapon customer james shaw junior
bulrush tim and was injured wrestling it
away
I saw the barrel of the of the
assault rifle aimed down and then I was
like I gotta go now I said it's either
Now or Never cuz he reloads it and it's
gonna be real bad without a gun and
naked Reinking fled on foot
sending authorities on a citywide search
the 29 year old has been on federal and
local law enforcement radar since last
July when he was arrested by the Secret
Service for entering a restricted area
near the White House for weapons
registered to Reinking were seized in
that arrest including the ar-15 used in
the Waffle House shooting ultimately the
seize firearms were returned to rankings
father who has admitted giving them back
to his son and that's despite the fact
Illinois officials say that rankings
father had agreed not to return the guns
to his son but did anyway here in
Nashville Tennessee authorities say
nothing under state law would have
prevented that now as for James Shaw jr.
he was grazed by a bullet in his arm his
hand was also burned when he grabbed a
hot barrel of the ar-15 everyone here is
calling him a hero but he's
uncomfortable that label was the first
time you realized that something was
wrong when I saw the probably the third
shot third or fourth shot and I saw the
Waffle House staff go like this like
they literally dropped in separate and
then I turned around I saw a guy on the
ground and then I was like oh my so what
did you do I grabbed him and I grabbed
the gun
I started hitting and punching and doing
anything I could could get the gun a jar
just kind of grabbed it from my LIF to
do real high not just tossed it over the
counter and what was everybody else
doing ducking hiding for cover and I
can't blame anybody can't blame anybody
for not helping me people calling you a
hero you know you save lives in there
what you don't see yourself as a hero
not only I think I want to be here I
think I just want to be James and James
used what he had to free himself and
miss the freedom himself he saved you
know people so Shaw who was a native of
Nashville just wishes he got to the
gunman faster as for the manhunt for
Reinking the primary focus is for two
square mile radius of this Waffle House
John Mark thanks James Shaw I want James
Shaw around when something happens not
just courage humility and what he said
to John that he doesn't blame anyone
thank you very much James Shaw jr. but
I'm thinking about mr.rai king's father
you certainly have some explaining to do
and I saw an interview with James Shaw
jr. saying he has a four year old
daughter and he kept thinking about her
- yeah he said his motivation if I was
going to die he was going to have to
work for it and in the afterwards he
said he wanted to get in touch with the
families of the victims make sure they
were okay
Thank You mr. Shaw I was trying